cette très jolie petite voiture est une
rené bonnet elle vient passer le week
end avec ses soeurs médina romorantin
dans l'ancienne usine
on a ça devait être la mécanique ça veut
dire touches mécaniques ici les deux
mécaniciens n'ont alloué pour marc jean
claude et ses anciens collègues de matra
voir ces petits bijoux de mécanique
poser dans la grande salle hennebicq de
la fabrique normand fait remonter des
souvenirs ici il y avait arlette tous à
nicole qu'il nettoyait les voitures ça
avance et nous ont contrôlé on était
deux contrôleurs et puis on mettait les
papiers sous les essuie glaces
c'est la première fois que je reviens
depuis 1981 je les voyais et quand ils
ont construit comme c'est maintenant je
dire que je travaillais là c'est ça qui
a fait pas ça ça fait une émotion quand
même sujet quitter la région parisienne
le 9 3 pour arriver ici à la campagne
bon je suis rentré dans cette cuisine en
tant que contrôleur c'était vraiment
super et j'ai passé de vraiment bon
moment 3au marquez a travaillé 37 ans
chez matra une vie il se souvient de la
bonne ambiance du début mais aussi des
périodes difficiles quand il a fallu se
mettre à produire de plus en plus en
1973 ça en faisait un maximum douches
par jour
on l'a fait et après les 60 la bagheera
on a monté à 50 morts en quelques mois
très peu en 73
avant la fin d'année je crois qu'on
était à 50 jours trop dur on n'était pas
habitué aux cadences
des glandes savez quoi il est loin le
temps où ces hommes fabriquer la matra
530 et son moteur central en toute
petite série entre 1964 et 2003 matra a
sorti en millions de voitures l'aventuré
industrielle s'est arrêté en 2003 avec
le licenciement de 1200 personnes
mais ce week end les anciens batraciens
l'assurent ils ne parleront que des bons
moments sur la douce musique de leur
moteur préféré grimper peu voilà c'est
bon t'es bon